[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur tv5 monde
et vos chaînes locales et régionales
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité des doutes encore mais une
perspective
c'est dans quinze jours environ que le
déconfinement débutera en france dans le
sud-ouest cafés et restaurants se
prépare déjà
comme l'a constaté sur place la chaîne
tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
la patrouille de france des rafales et
autres avions militaires au dessus de
l'île de beauté une base aérienne corse
a été l'hôte pendant plusieurs jours
d'équipages venus s'entraîner dans des
conditions idéales des images
époustouflantes de nos partenaires de
via télé plaiz et sur place une belle
histoire aussi dans ce grand gîte et des
territoires celle d'un athlète amputé
qui s'est relevé grâce à la boxe et qui
vise désormais les jeux olympiques à
bord d'une pirogue rencontre pleine de
courage
avec les rédactions de vie à vosges
enfin direction tahiti en fin de journal
c'est là que vit pierre cosso l'ancien
acteur idole du film la boum 2 et
partenaires fiancée de sophie marceau
aujourd'hui les chanteurs son nouveau
clip ainsi va la vie
une chanson pleine de vie et de bonne
humeur nous dira-t-il que nous
découvrirons en fin de journal on débute
ce journal avec ces quelques semaines
encore à tenir avant les premières
réouvertures le déconfinement des
terrasses pour les restaurants et les
cafés est prévue pour la mi mai selon
les engagements du gouvernement sans
attendre l'autorisation tant espérée
depuis six mois
certains professionnels se prépare déjà
les beaux jours arrivent et l'impatience
se fait sentir sur le littoral aquitain
où de nombreux passants profite du
soleil
reportage à lacanau de baptiste monge et
pour la chaîne du groupe sud ouest et
les sept un air de vacances plein
aujourd'hui en bord de mer ou surfer et
passants profiter du soleil
seul regret pour eux aujourd'hui
l'absence de terrasses
on a tous envie de faire autre chose que
de manger sur nos genoux les plats qui
sont remportés et puis pouvoir boire un
verre le soir ça pourrait être pas mal
de nos personnes âgées ça nous manque
c'est un lieu de rendez vous avec les
amis
ce restaurant de plage propose des
consommations emporté mais son patron
n'a qu'une hâte pouvoir servir ses
clients assis à table il faut que les
lieux soient tenues propre et façon on
se prépare à une réouverture dès que
possible avec les restrictions
sanitaires le manque à gagner est
conséquent pour les commerces au mois
d'avril en temps normal les campings et
hôtels sont remplis à 50% de leurs
capacités et c'est ça qui manque
on a aussi une fréquentation de
proximité en provenance de bordeaux
métropole où sont des personnes qui
viennent à la journée ou sur un week-end
ou des plus longs week-ends et qui
consomment beaucoup effectivement dans
les stations aujourd'hui ça nous réjouit
le coeur de voir un peu de monde mais
dans le centre-ville et sur le court
dans nos commerces fermés en attendant
la levée des restrictions les habitants
de lacanau qui profite de la vue à 6
peuvent se sentir privilégiés et puis
toujours du côté de bordeaux cette
information de nos confrères de radio
territoria stéphane fait faire adjoint
au maire de bordeaux europe ecologie les
verts en charge notamment du logement a
annoncé la diminution du nombre de
constructions neuves
chaque année dans la ville bordeaux
passera notamment de 4000 logements
neufs à 3000 dans des opérations
d'aménagement
écoutez à ce propos l'élu bordelais
jusqu'à présent on avait à peu près 4000
logements neufs dans tout bordeaux
chaque année une grosse partie qui est
sûre les opérations d'aménagement le
réseau diffus là l'objectif c'est de se
contenir à 3000 logements neufs dans les
opérations d'aménagement et entre 5 et 7
cents dans les opérations de diffusion
qu'on diminue la construction de
logements et qui reste largement en
adéquation avec le besoin de loges
pendant qu on est vraiment sur cet
objectif de diminution mais raisonnable
et raisonnée
l'actualité cette semaine c'est aussi le
retour sur les bancs de l'école des plus
jeunes
une rentrée après trois semaines d'arrêt
marquée par un protocole sanitaire très
stricte entre masques et test salivaire
regardez ce reportage près de cholet de
frédéric lamy pour la chaîne locale
tlc c'était une rentrée des classes
presque classique dans cette école de la
séguinière presque oui si l'obligation
de porter le masque est aujourd'hui
totalement intégrée par les enfants une
nouveauté de taille est venu renforcer
le protocole sanitaire
la changement c'est que à partir d'un
cas on ferme tout tout de suite la
classe comme le soulignait le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
il y aura donc nécessairement en nombre
non négligeable de fermeture de son côté
le premier ministre jean castex
affirmait que 400 mille tests salivaires
allait être déployé dans les écoles
élémentaires avec une concentration de
ce dispositif dans les départements où
l'incidence est la plus élevée à la
séguinière ce matin quasiment tous les
enfants étaient présents pour cette
rentrée
seule une poignée est absente soit des
jeunes diagnostiqués positifs pendant
les vacances soient des écoliers en
attente de résultats quoi qu'il en soit
la machine scolaire s'est remise en
route pour une longue période de 10
semaines et demi jusqu'au mardi 6
juillet de quoi inquiéter les
enseignants qui savent que cette
dernière ligne droite sera difficile
d'abord les apprentissages sont très
sont très important c'est le troisième
trimestre il ya beaucoup de choses qui
se passent les passages à la classe
supérieure le passage au collège moi
pour mes élèves et donc on est un petit
peu inquiet il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont été annulés enfin le protocole reste
inchangée conscient dans les cantines
ces dernières restent ouvertes tout en
conservant un dispositif stricte évitant
au maximum les brassages
mais même avec ces précautions elle
demeure une équation difficile à
résoudre
et avec le retour en présentiel des
écoliers les établissements font face à
la problématique de la propagation du
virus
comment limiter les contaminations
notamment au moment du repas dans les
collèges et lycées martinique et la
fermeture des réfectoires a été
préconisée par le rectorat
mais le défi n'est pas toujours facile à
réaliser c'est pour les aider que la
mission quand il a été créé un
représentant de la préfecture et un du
rectorat accompagne les établissements
pour faciliter l'application du
protocole de
puis le début de la semaine propos
recueillis par johan boulard et yvan le
marre de la rédaction de via à tv
martinique sur place par rapport à la
niche on a quand même moins d'élèves
donc on vérifie la capacité du reste de
la restauration
là on vérifie également l'aération 1
le service comment est il fait ça n'a
pas été que les élèves touches
différentes choses
donc là on est là dans le but
d'accompagner les chefs d'établissement
par rapport à cette problématique dans
second jt des territoires zuma présent
sur une initiative positive elle nous
vient aujourd'hui d'auvers sur oise en
ile de france où une supérette a décidé
de soutenir les restaurateurs locaux en
leur proposant un espace de vente dédié
dans ses rayons michaël joly pour vyas
95 regarde dans cette supérette du
centre ville d'auvers sur oise
tous les jours en fin de matinée un
rayon attire bon nombre de clients
al'approche de la pause déjeuner il
vient de choisir un plat à emporter
c'est connu alors rien du côté de port
caramel aux hommes grenaille et de la
brioche fourrée au chocolat
ces plats sont fabriqués par plusieurs
restaurateurs de la ville pour un plat
du jour il faut compter entre 5 et 10
euros et le concept séduit les clients
cette initiative qui est super pour des
gens qui travaillent qui n'ont pas tant
le
de faire à manger
qui arrive le soir tant que c'est pas
mal aussi peut-être pour des personnes
un pelage et compass toujours envie de
se faire à manger
une initiative lancée fin janvier par la
supérette qui par solidarité avec les
restaurateurs proposent les plats sans
aucune marge
un client qui m'a soumis l'idée qui lui
même avait vu un reportage
d'un magasin qui faisaient ça dans le
puy de dôme du coup je me suis dit que
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
fonctionner sur sur au vert j'ai mis un
post sur les groupes facebook de la
ville et les restaurateurs ont tout de
suite répondu présent parmi les trois
restaurants qui ont répondu présent le
café de la paix ce matin-là le gérant
termine la mise en barquettes des plats
qui seront vendus sur place et dans la
supérette avec ces deux modes de vente
qu'il en écoule entre 1500 et 1600 par
mois on diffuse un peu près 70 chats
sont plats par deux semaines à travers
ce carrefour qu'on fonctionne très bien
par ailleurs mais néanmois c'est un
petit plus que quand on est content il
ya environ un quart des barquettes
qu'ils partent parce par ce filon par
cette filière et nous fait les trois
quarts en forme direct ici la supérette
d'auvers-sur-oise n'exclut pas de
poursuivre la vente des plats des
restaurants
après leur réouverture dans son
appartement dans le jardin ou chez ses
parents les possibilités sont nombreuses
quand il faut travailler ailleurs qu'au
bureau on l'a vu pendant cette crise
sanitaire et certains privilégiés ont eu
la chance de pouvoir s'installer pour
quelques jours ou quelques mois sur des
îles au large des côtes françaises
à groix au sud de lorient ils sont
quelques dizaines à avoir pris le bateau
avec leur ordinateur un sujet de xavier
patrigeon pour la chaîne tébéo la chaîne
du groupe le télégramme en bretagne
après l'expérience des premiers
confinement et ceux d'aujourd'hui ils
sont quelques-uns à avoir choisi les
îles comme cadre de travail en
cohabitation apaisée avec les résidents
permanents
il faut replacer sur dans son contact
j'avais une psychose aussi ces pluies
il faut reconnaître que ya pas eu la
foule à venir il faut être sérieux
alors certains comme marie profite de la
maison familiale je sais que j'ai le
grand r je sais qu'il peut faire souvent
beau et ça permet de respirer je peux
aller faire du vélo le matin on avait
travaillé
et elle évolue dans le milieu du soutien
scolaire lui aussi en train de s'adapter
aux outils digitaux un monde ultra
connectés que renan a quant à lui voulu
éviter en louant cette petite maison
pour quelques mois
j'adore mon métier de professeur avec
les élèves mais ne fait là quand je suis
revenu d'un tour d'europe de me
retrouver tous les élèves avec tous les
masques et j'ai préféré la me couper de
quelques temps un cadre privilégié pour
travailler tout en s'évadant un peu ça
fait un an c'est un peu embêtant quand
même de rester dans son petit appart
parisien donc comme j'avais un ami qui
habite sur l'île de groix
il m'a proposé de venir ici le débit est
en effet plus limité que dans les
grandes villes rendant compliquée la
visioconférence notamment la fibre
optique a du retard et devrait être
installé d'ici la fin de l'année mais
cela n'arrête pas l'évolution du
télétravail en donnant même des envies
d'installations plus longue
les gens qui sont venus au départ et
puis qui ont trouvé que la vie était
sans doute plus facile basse et j'aurais
y consomment ou s'est il s de l'argent
dans les magasins de lille donc quand
ils sont ouverts on voit ce qui n'est
pas le cas actuellement
en attendant un retour presque à la
normale on profite du grand air et du
soleil entre deux mails
nous vous en parlions la semaine passée
les participants à l'expérience deep
times dans l'ariège sont sortis de leur
isolement après 42 jours passés à
plusieurs mètres sous terre dans une
grotte
cette aventure doit permettre d'étudier
l'adaptation de l'être humain au manque
de lumière naturelle et à la perte de
repères temporels la dépêche du midi nos
confrères et partenaires a pu rencontrer
certains de ces aventuriers dès leur
sortie
écoutez leurs réactions j'étais avec
plusieurs autres équipiers en train de
jouer aux cartes
et puis il s'est avéré que quand quand
on les a vus arriver qu'en fait on a
réalisé que ça y est c'est défini c'est
un chat qui j'étais plus du tout prête à
sortir c'était trop tôt la difficulté
venues pour certaines et certains de
s'affranchir de cette perpétuelle
aller-retour cognitif entre mais à
quelle heure et des corridors et quelle
heure il est chez nous voilà de couper
en fait avec le monde externe tout à
fait autre chose maintenant plus
habitués à les voir batailler avec le
feu les pompiers s'occupent aussi
parfois des sauvetages en mer à saint
malo ils viennent d'être équipés d'un
deuxième jet ski pour surveiller les
côtes dans la perspective de la
prochaine saison touristique
un sujet de philippe bertout pour la
chaîne tvn
il faudrait systématiser monté côté
bâbord vais sur l'arrivée ils font un 90
avec un lâcher plancha
leur redire en ligne les pompiers de
saint malo viennent de recevoir leur
deuxième jet ski de reconnaissance et de
sauvetage et cette semaine l'heure est à
la formation avec exercices de
récupération de victimes en difficulté
face à vive allure auprès de auprès de
la victime pour déposer un équipier et
avoir une récupération extrêmement
rapide
entre deux trains drac l'intérêt de ce
type d'embarcation pouvoir se rapprocher
des plages des côtes rocheuses et
évoluer dans des zones exiguës
on peut virer sur place on peut
intervenir dans des trains de vagues
resserré et avoir une vitesse de sortie
en zone de fuites beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus importante
effectivement ce type de jet dispose de
180 chevaux et permet d'atteindre les
100 km heure à pleine puissance
ainsi 34 sapeurs-pompiers de la
spécialité sauvetage côtier seront
opérationnels d'ici le début de l'été
ils interviendront entre saint briac et
la baie du mont saint michel de la mer
au vol en plein air dans ce grand jt des
territoires avec ses belles images de la
base aérienne de ventiseri solenzara en
corse qui a accueilli pendant plusieurs
jours différents équipages patrouille de
france équipe de france de voltige ou
encore rafale une semaine de vol et de
préparation pour les pilotes dans des
conditions très particulières
en effet au dessus de la mer il est plus
difficile de se repérer explications au
micro de via tel est pas aisé sur place
nous sommes tous ici présents tous les
ambassadeurs de l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace pour le stage maritime
c'est un entraînement en environnement
marin l'objectif c'est d'évoluer au
dessus de la mer avec des repères qui
sont bien sûr très différent de la terre
l'objectif c'est vraiment d'appréhender
la hauteur par rapport à l'eau et les
repères qui sont différents
place à l'économie maintenant dans ce
grand jt des territoires direction le
doubs avec vous michel picaud bonjour
aujourd'hui nous allons découvrir l'une
des dernières maisons d'horlogerie haut
de gamme indépendante
ledoux s'est longtemps illustré dans ce
domaine avec ses maisons de prestige
aujourd'hui il reste encore quelques
unes comme la maison péquignet bonjour
sert il bonjour à tous morteau dans le
doubs qui s'est longtemps illustré par
son industrie horlogère au début du 20e
siècle
mais il faut dire qu'une grande partie
de nos créateurs français ont depuis
traversé la frontière
direction la suisse pays de l'horlogerie
mondiale mais heureusement il reste
encore quelques maisons horlogères et
effectivement je voulais vous parler de
la maison paix qu'il y ait créé par
emile péquignet en 1973 juste avant la
première faillite de la maison l'ip
aujourd'hui péquignet est l'une des
dernières maisons horlogères française
réellement indépendante qui a su garder
la maîtrise de ses créations et de sa
fabrication
l'entreprise a été reprise en 2010 est
par quatre anciens cadres de la maison
qui ont souhaité recentrer leurs
collections autour de l'adn de la marque
et ils ont même créé leur propre
mouvement le fameux tic tac d'une montre
leur mouvement s'appelle calibre royal
et il est le seul et unique calibre
français de haute horlogerie
depuis le calibre initiale a également
vu le jour il ya un an plus petit moins
cher et moins complexe
il vient étoffer l'offre de la maison
une montre contenant jusqu à 398 pièce
miniaturisés pour vous donner heure
minute seconde date face de lune heures
gmt et une réserve de marche une fois
remonté de 88 eur péquignet certainement
la seule entreprise existante en france
à concevoir réaliser commercialiser ses
propres montre qu'ils commencent
d'ailleurs à s'exporter un peu partout
dans le monde
au japon par exemple cette montre avec
son propre mouvement mécanique qui
s'appelle dans ma langue calibre royal
est bien là bas on l'appelle tout
simplement jardin à la française
merci michel picaud tout à fait autre
chose maintenant direction l'aube à
présent c'est au tour de la ferme
pédagogique de méry-sur-seine que va
s'établir l'unique conservatoire de
france dédié exclusivement à la race de
poules et de coques gauloise saumon doré
objectif de cette belle initiative
sauver la génétique de la race mais
aussi un peu un pan du patrimoine
français le coq gaulois est quand même
l'emblème de notre pays un reportage de
la rédaction de canal 32 sur place les
oreillons qui doivent être bien blanc
des yeux rouges orangés voilà avec la
base de la queue m qui pompon blanc
comme ça établir à méry-sur-seine
l'unique conservatoire en france de la
race gauloise son monde aurait le projet
est en train d'éclore
après cinq ans de travail ça fait dix
ans que je vois des poussins être ça
fait quelque chose
et là c'est un petit peu particulier il
ya un stress en plus se dire il faut que
ça fonctionne pour sauvegarder le
patrimoine et la génétique de la race
damien vidal a parcouru 4000 km et
rencontré une douzaine d'éleveurs de
quimper à poitiers en passant par les
alpes et dijon il est revenu avec 24
souche différente et 459 on arrive sur
le printemps donc le printemps s'est
scellée naissance c'est les éclosions
donc on a fait venir les et d'un peu
partout et oui aujourd'hui et hier et
dans les jours qui vont venir les
naissances arrive sur le conservatoire
après la couveuse et les clauses war
direction la poussinière où les poules
et coqs gaulois découvre un autre
univers ils s'installeront ensuite
quelques semaines dans ses boxes
réhabilité en poulailler avant d'être
exposée et étudié dans trois immense
volière en cours de construction
si on a 500 de petits on va pas garder
500 petits évidemment nous regarder la
génétique pour pouvoir faire de la
reproduction sur les années futures et
le reste des sujets sont souvent être
évidemment à vendre des personnes qui
veulent dans le futur acquiert coqs et
poules qu'après le conservatoire on a
cherché à à diffuser un maximum grâce
pour qu'on puisse la retrouver
facilement dans tous les départements de
france le projet de conservatoire se
fait en lien étroit avec le conseil
départemental et l'inra l'institut
national de recherche agronomique le
pari de sauver une espèce rustique et
emblématique est en passe d'être gagné
une leçon de vie et de sport dans ce
grand jt des territoires en 2003 abel
abers été victime d'un accident de
scooter
amputé de la jambe droite le ring lui a
permis de se relever
devenu sportif de haut niveau il se
lance un nouv
au défi participer aux jeux
paralympiques de paris en 2024 dans la
discipline du paracanoë son parcours
exceptionnel nous est racontée par denis
le kent et marie danielle rogowicz pour
vient vosges en 2003 à belladères été
victime d'un accident de scooter
amputé de la jambe droite il s'est
relevé au prix d'une insatiable
persévérance il a tiré un trait sur une
carrière rêver de militaires mais aura
combattu ses démons intérieurs
le ring a été son exutoire au départ
j'avais osé pousser la porte mais un peu
à l'abri des regards donc je cachais
beaucoup ma jambe et je boxais petit à
petit ça ça m'a permis de m'ouvrir
j'étais dans différentes salles et puis
quand survenue en 2008 avec
jean-françois vu ces galaxies gym il a
vu que je m'occupais pas mal de jeunes
il serait bien que tu en cadets que tu
vois pourquoi pas une arène avenir
professionnel
abel devient un sportif de haut niveau
compétiteurs puis il obtient son diplôme
d'entraîneur de boxe thaï éducateur
auprès des jeunes médiateurs dans les
quartiers il fait la fierté de celui qui
l'accompagné quand on est un peu
fatigués ou fut dit aux autres élèves
quand ils viennent sont un peu fatigués
pour ce qu'elle accorde moi la seule
plus la seule réponse que j'ai aussi
regardé la belle
à 34 ans l'athlète spinaliens toujours à
la force de ses bras s'est lancé un
nouveau défi sur l'eau cette fois ci
c'est une période de vraie de course en
ligne adaptés pour le sprint un musée à
peu près 7 mètres et un flotteur côté
gauche coteaux que j'ai plus de quoi du
côté où j'ai la jambe valide
abel a mis la barre très haut et vise
les jeux olympiques en 2024 à paris pour
participer aux épreuves de paracanoë
avec l'espoir d'une médaille
abel est aussi repéré par le comité
paralympique et sportif français qui
détecte les futurs talents
mais il doit faire mieux que son chrono
actuel de 55 secondes sur 200 m quelques
efforts encore sur la glisse et la
vitesse et abel pourrait dès cet été et
prendre la direction des jeux de tokyo
alors une pagaie 100 ans l'âge pour
atteindre cet horizon en bleu nous
partons dans le nord maintenant sur le
littoral ce blockhaus ne brille plus
entre 2014 et 2015
l'ouvragé militaire est passé de l'ombre
à la lumière grâce à bertrand seguin
alias l'anonyme l'artiste l'avait
tablier de milliers de morceaux de
miroir et malgré le succès public de son
oeuvre il n'a plus aujourd'hui les
moyens de l'entretenir seul et a décidé
de le démonter les précisions sur place
de caroline fichten pour l'achat nous et
où la chaîne de la voix du nord nos
partenaires des milliers de morceaux de
verre et des millions de coups de burin
pour les faire tomber au sol
le blockhaus miroir de le frein cook
retrouve au fil des jours son aspect
originel et perd de son éclat
pour l'artiste il y a dans le démontage
de son oeuvre des sentiments mêlés
sentiment un peu de tristesse forcément
parce que ça a été une grosse partie de
ma vie ça fait cette année de réflexion
ça pourrait faire penser à vous non d'un
film et voilà bon écoutez quand même la
satisfaction et c'était un super par un
énorme pari un énorme challenge
l'artiste a passé trois mois tous les
ans à entretenir son oeuvre une
subvention proposée par la région
l'année dernière aurait permis de
financer cet entretien subventions qui a
été refusé par la ville de
leffrinckoucke résultats donc l'oeuvre
est en cours de démontage et les
promeneurs trouve ça dommage basse a eu
une belle époque qui se termine et elles
s'étaient tous ses reflets qui est qui
brillait jeu pendant toutes les yeux des
personnes du qu'ils ont beaucoup et
retiré cette oeuvre et du
nord-pas-de-calais
ben ça m'inspire un peu de tristesse
parce que c'est vrai que même je
conseillais déjà des touristes qui
venaient dans le dunkerquois d'aller
voir ça parce que c'est exceptionnel
le démontage est presque terminée de
loin le blockhaus a déjà perdu de sa
particularité et ressemble désormais à
beaucoup d'autres vestiges présent sur
les plages de la région
voilà après le nord de la france
direction la polynésie française
direction tahiti bonjour pierre cosso
bonjour serré le pire qu'aux vous êtes
connus notamment des téléspectateurs
pour avoir joué dans le film la boum et
d'y avoir incarné le célèbre petit ami
de sophie marceau
un rôle qui vous collent toujours
d'ailleurs à la peau aujourd'hui mais
vous êtes aussi un artiste et vous venez
de sortir votre dernier morceau avec
votre groupe qu'aux and co il s'appelle
ainsi va la vie
c'est le nom de cette chanson extrait de
ce club le lundi je deviens écolo ou
j'atteins qu'un régime
bio oui c'est ça bio mais dès le
mercredi je fonce au mcdo j'ai la haine
des entailles une défense le cerveau
devient hystérique du qui a plus de
réseau voilà le ton le rythme les
couleurs sont évidemment positive cela
vous correspond à vous même et votre
groupe vous connais un peu mais le
message de cette chanson est il
davantage dénonciateurs est ce que les
réseaux sociaux sont en question
notamment
et pourquoi en fait ça faisait longtemps
que j'avais envie de de mettre le doigt
sur toutes les absurdités convient
actuellement notamment à travers les
réseaux sociaux
l'internet et sur tous les smartphones
moi je fais partie de la génération qui
a connu l'avant réseaux sociaux et je
peux vraiment faire une grande
différence aujourd'hui et se montrent
d'abord me manque et c'est peut-être un
peu pour ça que j'ai écrit cette chanson
la bonne humeur transpire quand même
dans ce clip on le disait cette chanson
c'est une volonté du groupe dans cette
période si particulière et si difficile
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui
pierre cosso justement la période et les
particuliers à huy
non la chansonnette en polynésie on a la
chance de vivre sous le soleil est
entourée du plus grand océan du monde
on a quand même été pas mal épargné par
le cos vide même si nous avons eu des
morts mais on peut encore continuer à se
produire
musicalement il ya encore des spectacles
donc on avait vraiment envie de
communiquer cette cette joie et parce
qu'on est quand même sensible à ce qui
se passe dans le reste du monde plus que
sensible on est on est concerné donc on
avait vraiment envie de sortir un le
premier titre de l'album une chanson
avec du soleil et de la bonne humeur
pierre cosso quelles sont vos prochaines
étapes avec ce groupe
alors on espère dans un futur proche
la réouverture du monde à la musique à
l'amour au partage et on espère vraiment
pouvoir faire une tournée en france en
italie et en allemagne
nous sommes sept dans le groupe nous
sommes nous sommes sur les starting
blocks
voilà on a beaucoup de choses à raconter
on a des moments de joie à vivre avec le
public comme dans cette chanson ainsi va
la vie et on espère de tout coeur
retrouvez la vie d'avant un album est
prévu pour le mois de juin et et on
espère vraiment pouvoir venir année le
sol et de la polynésie en europe très
prochainement
voilà merci pierre cosso d'avoir été mon
invité on espère aussi que le soleil de
tahiti pourra très vite arriver chez
nous en europe
au revoir et à bientôt pierre merci
cyril de m'avoir invité c'est la fin de
ce grand jt des territoires merci de
nous avoir suivi sur tv5 monde et aux
chaînes locales et régionales de la tnt
a très vite pour une prochaine édition
au courage à tous
[Musique]